écriture de scénario confection de mini
décor réalisation ou encore montage
voilà les ateliers proposés aux enfants
de la ville de guingamp cours des
activités qui les passionne ça se passe
bien bas au début j'avais jamais essayé
nous stoppe prochaine après au fil au
fil du temps et bunge condensats à
comprendre
on pense à quelque chose ça vient après
ben on a une idée on essaye de le faire
et après ben c'est après le reste et de
l'improvisation
au début c'était compliqué mais après
enfin je crois que je me suis bien amusé
on a fait on a fait bouger les
personnages on a fait ce qu'on voulait
tremblement terre ou autres chefs c'est
être lien et pour les petits spielberg
en herbe le but de l'atelier est de
découvrir et s'initier au stop motion
c'est un système d'animation qui date
depuis très longtemps c'est d'être
depuis le début du cinéma
donc c'est une technique qui consiste à
faire bouger un beau justin objets
immobiles et à la fin la nuit l'exemple
vous avez 6 avec king kong en noir et
blanc en pâte à modeler ça c'est du stop
motion c'est à dire que on part sur un
objet on va animer avec la pâte à
modeler et c'est ça et à la fin on le
déplace un petit peu on prend des photos
et à la fin en assemblant les photos on
voit l'objet qui bouge et durant les
deux semaines plus de 5000 photos ont
été prises des différents courts
métrages seront visionnées par les
enfants à la fin des vacances de noël